look at this Knight C4 Bishop C7 you
might just win a pawn
not quite yet though the Knight
defending that square but at the moment
it moves you are leaning into C7 all
right I got you I gotcha I got you all
right that's on the piece there yeah but
you know it's my rules of commentary you
always have to be willing to be
incorrect I blundered a piece it happens
but no Bishop C7 would be great except
for the oh no way
oh my gosh
are you kidding me
[Music]
Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura the speed
Chess Championship final two of the
greatest chess players to ever exist
going head-to-head across three intense
hours of Blitz and bullet chess
Magnus entered the match as a big fan
favorite having won their two previous
matches in the format by convincing
margins but Hikaru had made big strides
in his game since their last match and
in their seven games so far in 2022
Magnus had not beaten Hikaru and Hikaru
had two wins
the first game was dramatic but mostly
balanced as Magnus surprised Hikaru with
an opening shot in Bishop to F3 check
whoa look at this oh the following I had
a game just like this against ding in
the Pro chess League two years ago I
remember this move Bishop F3 check
catches a car by surprise he looks upset
right now in a balanced end game both
Players missed a chance for Hikaru to
take a Pawn on H7 and ultimately they
repeated moves in the second game Magnus
met hikaru's King's Indian with the
surprising Bishop to D3 and he seized a
big space advantage and was pressing
hard could he break through in the time
scramble and I don't know with two
seconds is he gonna decide on C5 he
decides to exchange trucks but he gives
up the pawn oh my God and he's giving up
another one I think it's just a draw
Queen E1 and we have a drama repetition
by lands and Magnus doesn't decide on C5
it was difficult to calculate the
ramifications especially against dicaro
it's a drop by Perpetual check
game three looks like a dead equal
snooze Fest but then Hikaru stole a pawn
and cemented a big night on B7 1967
Magnus is starting to lose control kid
he trapped this Knight though Hikaru can
save it with his Pawn C5 and C6 he
drives the pawn and he cuts off the king
yes C6 the king cannot get in there
Bishop B16 E6 the king can't get to the
pawn oh he's gonna play he's got a flag
he lost
and he can't believe it and look at
Hikaru he's cool as a cucumber he just
focused and he's acting like nothing
just happened but something huge
happened he gained the lead it's the
first lead in this match and it belongs
to Kara Nakamura insane after that
shocking time forfeit Hikaru had the
first lead of the match and he was
clearly feeling some momentum while
Magnus seemed all out of sorts
Carlson pressed again with a space
advantage in game four but Hikaru showed
his famous defensive skills and he held
on in the mutual time scramble
was the move for E5 a mouse slip or a
dubious opening Try by Magnus in game 5.
either way Hikaru laughed and continued
confidently establishing a big Advantage
18 Knight G5 was a nice and accurate
move by Hikaru he goes Knight G5 hitting
the H7 Pawn the queen has to take the
Knight the bishop takes the bishop on B7
and after black with Rook a to B8 saving
the Rook attacking the bishop C7 Pawn
balls white goes up a pawn and looks
like a healthy extra Pawn so unless
Magnus can drum up some counter play he
is simply worse Magnus has literally two
moves to drum something up because that
pawn is reaching A8 in a tizzy and
Magnus Flags it's over Hikaru now led by
two and a confident hold with black
against Magnus in game six kept the edge
as they headed to the seventh game where
Magnus surprised Hikaru by playing the
king's Indian himself and akaru laughed
as he deployed Magnus earlier Bishop D3
idea
Hikaru found a nice idea with Knight to
F5 to gain some Edge but in the time
scramble things got very messy you swap
queens and win the D5 Knight so you know
you got to keep your material and
speaking of material white is only up
one pump Queen except the queen takes B5
is a Desperado he's gotta move his gosh
wait what does Magnus do
is nice
and then Rook 65 at the end and then
Knight oh Knight's not trap is rugby
eight wow this goes right for the pawn
he just wants an attack of the car could
even play like King A1 Bishop B1 he can
curl up into a ball instead he
eliminates the attacker
and his Rook takes a two impossibility
but the car going for mate he wants
rookies oh my God
one second up Magnus lose on time Hikaru
Nakamura sticks a knife on F6 and it is
knockout five to two is the score
nobody's counting back as Carlson out
but who would have believed that Hikaru
Nakamura would jump out to a three-point
lead this early in the match Magnus
repeated his opening from the fourth
game in game eight but again Hikaru
defended well and all of a sudden his
Knight leapt into D3 setting up
brilliant threats because Knight D3
instead using the Knight to hop in and
that Rook can go to C3 the queen go to
G4 Knight F4 check is available this is
Scary For What Black's position is
filled to the brim with tactical
potential and what's not filled to the
brim look at magnus's clock he is again
down two minutes and the position is
just getting more and more out of hand
it is he's just allowing I have four
Knight of four Knight F4 and it's mate
yeah hey car season he's a car can't
believe it he looked at this
this is basic Brian Robert this is an
idea that occurs across all openings
this is universal and you can't step
back to the first rank because of Rook
C1 with mate it's over yeah no Hikaru
saw it and look at him he's like are you
serious am I really playing Magic this
is all you got he says to Magnus he's
gonna be up four points and Magnus has
got a match on his hands doesn't he oh a
match I mean he's gonna have to work
hard to stay evil queen H3 look at that
mate
yeah
that's over
another surprise opening from Magnus in
game nine as he played the night orph
this would be the final game of the five
plus one time control a daring Queen
side castle by Magnus allowed Hikaru big
chances and suddenly the idea of
trapping the queen lurked in the
position so I feel like here Hikaru if
he finds B3 that just shows The
Sensational forms it but he plays Knight
D5 I anticipate this would happen and
Dania now I really feel like Magnus the
chance of this game is Alaska station
for the queen though Hikaru had missed a
clear win he was still pressing hard
when something insane happened and the
white king will be victim to a lot of
checks so that's the one bit of good
news Bishop G6 he plundered and
magnificent
Magnus to play too quickly Bishop G
em attack on the
under seven was hit as well
unbelievable blunder Magnus is not even
thinking about it because he's just he's
so used to losing games I think inertia
just carried him forward Bishop G6 a
discovered attack and you couldn't take
the bishop not because you lost the Rook
but because you got mated after that
and listen a good practical call by
Hikaru no need to do anything crazy the
only winning move there was Queen C7 to
E7 but how hard is that to see with two
seconds
six and a half two and a half after the
five plus one time control Hikaru led by
four and was still undefeated by Magnus
in 2022
with a break to rest before the three
plus one time control Magnus came out
strong getting a very magnusy positional
advantage and pressing hard with his
past C Pawn I love that move love the
move for P5
only move to win apparently according to
the engine
and hit cards is gonna lose some time
Magnus was on the board and had his
first win against icaro in all of 2022.
in their second three plus one game The
Players repeated their opening from game
one but this time Hikaru found the
bishop takes H7 idea to steal a pawn
although it was not enough to win
a fairly boring draw in the next game
preceded a huge hold by Magnus in a
difficult spatial squeeze and this has
been phenomenal defense thus far by
Magnus Carlson but can he keep it up
rook to AJ preparing to occupy the open
file he's created for himself he's got
the most counter play he's had in a
while don't work B8 down a pawn he goes
for being I'm wondering if Brook 65 will
be played by a card that would be an
incredible call and very risky move but
a potentially rewarding move that night
is a beast
but no a draw and a dodged Bullet by
Magnus the next game was shaping up to
see Magnus be the one squeezing when
commentator Robert Hess jinxed him look
at this Knight C4 Bishop C7 you may just
win a pawn
not quite yet though the night defending
that square but the moment it moves you
are leaning into C7 all right I got you
I got you I got you all right that's
wrong the piece there yeah but you know
it's my rules and comments here you
always have to be willing to be
incorrect I blundered a piece it happens
but no Bishop C7 would be great except
for the oh no way oh my gosh
oh my gosh
are you kidding me I think I should
apologize is this a dream
if it is a card never wants to wake up
hikaru's lead was up to four and he
looked poised to expand it with a big
Knight takes F7 shot in the next game
but look at the car he's spotting the
tactics Queen E7 play look wait a second
it was was 96 the best move because I
feel oh
yeah once we got here the evaluation
went down and the reason why is if Queen
E7 Bishop takes back you take this on B7
C3 Falls B4 Falls next and the Knight is
kind of Trapped stranded on B7 Perpetual
it might be time for white to bail out
you could take on B6 I feel like ah but
then Queen D5
is Magnus the one going for it no he
can't go King G6 can he after hikaru's
night sack it was now Magnus turned to
second night with a textbook
continuation oh on A6 is there a knight
B5 Rook season 7.5 that is sick the
bishop 105 is loose as is The Rook on
eight and look at Magnus he's looking at
the board from the side and I think he
can't miss this he can't he has to find
the move and Knight takes D5 does the
same thing right
it might have even been better Knight
takes D5 there might have was Bishop B6
and Magnus delivers he had no right to
miss that tactic this is what he eats
not for breakfast he he eats harder
tactics than this for breakfast and a
big missed by Hikaru how lost is this
Robert is this just up on down and
you're losing a second pawn and your
position is collapsing or is there any
hope for Hikaru uh in the ensuing
position it looks extremely lost you
have to take on C7 now right I don't see
another move and after Queen takes D5
loose pieces drop off lpdo says Donna
nerdinsky The Rook on eight is loose the
bishop on F5 excuse me is similarly
loose and so you lose a pawn the np5
drops and you're gonna lose this game so
the break could not have come at a
better time for Magnus Hikaru put up
strong defense but he could not hold it
in the end though he did drain a lot of
time off of the match clock and he
amusingly utilized the heck out of that
strategy in the next game dramatically
thinking three minutes off of the clock
with a forced repetition sitting on the
board I know there's a force draw here
there's some sort of draw yes that's it
and he car was going for it and he's
forgotten about it I think yeah this was
from Lev Albert's uh perk alert that
book from way back in the day I had that
book I played this opening from black
and the point is Bishop F2 check King D2
Bishop E3 is a force draw if you take
the queen on d8
now white has the possibility of playing
Knight B5 he car is not gonna dip his
toes into that toxic pool he's gonna
accept the draw a great result for
Magnus but he's not gonna accept it
again yes so hikara's clock getting two
minutes and 30 seconds he's gonna take
it down all the way to a couple seconds
and then he's gonna play King D2 and
King e went back black has no choice
you've given up your queen and so you
have to play this forcing sequence
efficient E3 check and Bishop check he
can't be happy with the way he's playing
but he's definitely happy there's time
left on the clock for making one more
move and now he's gonna wait again uh
he's not waiting he's thinking
he could spend this time thinking about
how to play as black so that's exactly
what he is thinking about is the next
game the next opening what he should do
and well this game is about to be a draw
as soon as king U1 is played
and don't lose on time there we go okay
when it mattered most with time
dwindling in the three plus one time
control Magna showed off some of his
best chests of the match first finding a
fine tactic to win upon it's winning
he's on knocking on the door of having
this lead can he finish it off whoa it
goes there always Bishops he takes up
six he's winning what recognition and
this is winning King F6
just go back you can take five I don't
move the position was still incredibly
difficult to win but Magnus showed some
outstanding technique in the end game
okay she's four and Rook F4 it's not
over yet he Karma look at this
he is this is insane
and this was necessary because Hikaru
would have otherwise given up the rook
and traded the last pair of Pawns there
was just enough time for one more three
plus one game but the players repeated
the martial line that had only led to
draw so far and again the ultimate
result was equality
with that Magnus won the three plus one
time control by two points but he was
still behind by two heading into the
bullet time control
Magnus had momentum but he did not get
off to a good starting bullet as he
allowed a fine Knight F4 move by Hikaru
that set up some beautiful tactics
imagine just playing smart chest
midnight at four
First Sight he has to move the bish op
gives secara with Tempo now it's not the
end of the world because his Pawn
structure can sustain it but he'll need
to smoke that night out of f4 ASAP white
has the structural Advantage but he
wonders with Nike too with me too oh
what a move oh what a tactic in game one
of the bullet it's gonna win a pawn the
knights dropping back to C4 and Hikaru
is basically winning in the end game and
you saw Magnus he's like yep I missed
that one and ikaru needs to put this one
away it will give him a three-point lead
but what a mistake by Magnus Carlsen he
is just an off-form in so many of these
games
gosh Bishop G4 check it Bishop me to
this Rook F1 check things like that it
looks so very very bad for Magnus Hikaru
sees it
guess what he's doing something he's
never done before he's bringing some
time off the clock resign right now if
you're Magnus Knight C3 oh and he does
that's it Magnus was unfazed by being
back down to three and he pushed hard in
the next game creating some dangerous
past pawns on the king side and
ultimately winning out when things got
messy oh this is not looking good for
Magnus no it isn't A2 it's also a bit
loose so you if you take it right off
the pawn you could lose the A2 when he
goes oh my gosh
where do you go you have to give up A2
you called it should be two here comes
should pay two now oh hey Cara's
collapsing he's losing control of the
game Bishop E4 and eg3 was winning and
look at that and what for the quickest
checkmate
yep clinical Until the End even with two
Queens on the board he ain't lazy every
second matters here and only seven
minutes have gone off the match clock so
it has not been a catastrophe Magnus
gets this lead back to two and another
pivotal game with the white pieces in
the following game a quick tactic was a
game Ender whatever you do don't lose
this game if you're Magnus this would be
a heartbreaker 9600 a piece oh my gosh
signs right away so see
akaro feel
slipping so instead of just wasting time
he's like I need to get in the flow
because right now he is a bit rattled
and Magnus Carlson has cut the lead to
just one point the players went into the
Marshall again in the next game and
Hikaru was pressing hard when the
critical moment arrived with Magnus
attacking F2 while Hikaru was going
after magnus's King in the center of the
board
he left the king slip
and there was Bishop C7 there but still
this looks like anybody's going oh
my God Bishop C7 threading mate if you
haven't tried Queens but now black is up
a pot all of a sudden and G3
but so is H7 this is still a three
result game with two seconds Anything
Can Happen a mouse slip a blunder Rook
have five another excellent move Robert
he's going for that pawn he goes keys in
is that Rook trapped Bishop A6 forces
take it watch out the 87 Pawn is safe
and sound and H6 is a problem
you might lose this if black wins H6 he
wins the game now if you're Magnus do
not flag do not flag F6 F6 quick move
Bishop GA draw that's a good awareness
no you can't take it oh you can't you
can't take the Pod it's tied Hikaru
resides and we have a tied match with 17
minutes to go for the first time since
the beginning of this match Magnus
Carlson is level with three wins in a
row Magnus had tied up the match the
following game appeared to be heading to
a drawn Rook end game but then Hikaru
found an unexpected opportunity with
Rook C4 you try to squeeze just because
you have the upper hand you've got the
car oh apparently Rook C4 here might win
a second Pawn no way the Rook eight
Eights
oh and then Rook takes B4 Magnus just
blundered with C5 he he rushed it oh my
goodness he rushed it huge moment this
game
how does he my Lance how can he survive
here
I don't think he can I think he's gonna
end up two pawns down and that is still
salvageable in some cases but not here
well you zigzag your way through but the
eval bar 2.2 is like Fortress 53
blunders Hikaru kept the pressure up in
the next game as well and he found a
strong idea to trap magnus's Queen
Carlson once again dude this is already
heroic defense wow holding on G6 oh but
the Queen's getting a trap G4 is coming
it's Unstoppable that is crazed in F5
and so what awareness from ikaru Queen
H5 get rid of the pawn
the bishop
even better
Karu is a beast oh but what a move by
Magnus GF that does nothing that didn't
work couldn't have taken the Rook
there was definitely still time
remaining for Magnus to come back from
down two but it was going to be tight he
played a great game with white and one
in the end but it was a long game and it
used a lot of time he was now down one
with five minutes remaining
in the next game Hikaru showed that he
was not satisfied to play solidly with
white and try to hold on to his Edge he
pushed his Pawn up to A6 setting up some
nice tactics later in the game there was
only 3 minutes and 20 seconds left in
the match clock Magnus had to win
quickly to have any chance of starting
one more final game and winning that one
as well to force tie breaks initially it
did not look like he would be able to
win this game much less win quickly but
then he got an edge in The Rook end game
and he quickly turned that into a
Winning Edge would he be able to win it
though before Hikaru drained the
remaining clock time
verge of an SEC Championship he is in
the driver's seat he's not losing this
game with the black pieces
unless something just happened oh he did
he blundered the pawn now he's got 50
seconds he might even be able to build
up enough time to bleed it out it's
gonna be really close but Magnus has
winning chances now oh for sure he'll go
after oh my gosh before at some point
but one Robert 35 seconds remaining on
the mass clock look at what he car is
doing he's just playing instantly he's
trying to bleed this out he's got 40
more seconds
he's lost he's
got enough time oh my gosh Magnus has to
show off the mouse speed right now
because this is a winning position for
white he is winning a second Pawn just
like a car did in a previous game Magnus
cannot afford to waste a single second
this could be over if Hikaru can bleed
another minute off the batch clock here
we go one minute 10 seconds every second
counts King 86 he's gonna win G5
and kg7 it's winning oh my God no but
Hikaru he has 15 more seconds he needs
to bleed 15 seconds king of eight
move if you're Magnus your car is gonna
make it happen
he wins the speech Chess Championship
Magnus gives a little bit clap forehead
car Nakamura but what a performance from
the American Superstar he has won the
Fisher random World Championship this
year he's winning title Tuesday pretty
much twice every single Tuesday and now
he has taken the speed Chess
Championship that is your streamer that
is your SCC winner of 2022.
Hikaru Nakamura is the 2022 speed chess
champion the Chess World has been
waiting five years for the speed Chess
Championship rematch and it delivered in
every possible way both players were
open cheerful and appreciative of their
opponents in their post-match interviews
no I mean I I think the thing is I'm
playing Magnus I mean if you can't get
excited by playing Magnus then why are
you even playing shots I mean he's the
best player in the world he's the world
champion if you can't if you can't be
excited then like there's something
wrong with you he's uh he's amazing at
this
uh at this format I remember
his match against feducev two years ago
he's five plus uh one segment there I
felt that that's pretty much just
as well as it possible to play
um
in that particular time control and I
did feel today that he came sort of uh
at least very close to to that level so
you know had stuff for for that that was
um
um not not fun to to face
um that particular segment but it was um
it was amazing to see
foreign
[Music]